now it's been four years since the
United Nations adopted its sustainable
development goals meant to improve the
lives of billions of people by 2030 but
a third of the way towards the deadline
a review has found that the world is
likely to fail to meet its commitments
for education under these sustainable
development goals all children should be
in school by 2030 but at present rates
of progress are 14% will still not be in
education by then illiteracy all young
people should be able to read and write
by 2030 but it's feared that 20% will
still be illiterate projections are
worse for low-income countries like
Pakistan it's expected that a quarter of
the country's their children won't
complete their secondary education by
the 2030 deadline DW has been to visit a
school there to see what is being done
to get kids into school and to keep them
there it's 8 o'clock in the morning and
Sajid Muhammad should be getting ready
for school but the 12 year old stopped
going a few years ago in order to work
and support his family I come here early
in the morning and stay till late which
is very tiring when I get home I have a
bath and go to the mosque we don't have
money which is why I can no longer study
Sajit situation is the norm for millions
of children across Pakistan a new report
from UNESCO estimates some 5.3 million
are out of school at the primary level
and girls lose out the most 21% are
married as children and afterwards stop
going to school Pakistan's continuing
education crisis is mainly down two
decades of underinvestment and
mismanagement of the entire system and
faith in politicians to finally improve
things is so low that many people are
taking matters into their own hands
[Music]
[Applause]
this school was established by
volunteers in karachi offering free
lessons to the nearby fishing community
the classes offer an escape to expose
and hope for a better future forced to
open this school as there are no
functioning government ones in the area
many of our children are getting into
trouble especially with drugs we tried
to get support from the government and
pressed them to help us but heard
nothing back this is why we set it up
ourselves we play games and really enjoy
ourselves they teach as well so we like
coming here I want to study and become a
pilot when I grow up they teach us in
English and Urdu I want to learn here
and then become a teacher myself Prime
Minister Imran Khan has vowed to
prioritize and invest in education but
the government continues to spend less
than is recommended by international
standards education should be the
priority of government so even if they
have plies what I personally feel is
where we fail is when we are
implementing it if things are moving in
the same direction
I don't think so we'll be able to
achieve this target within 20 2030 goal
we won't be able to achieve
Sajid says he would love to become a
police man but the only real hope he and
millions like him have is if Pakistan
not only seriously reforms its education
system but also lifts families like
sergeants out of poverty to send their
children to school work cut out
according to the latest UN forecast one
in four children will not complete their
education by 2030 now one of the
organizations that had a hand in setting
these sustainable development goals is
the UN Development Programme its
administrator is former New Zealand
Prime Minister Helen Clark she joins us
from The Hague
welcome to DW getting children into
school and raising an educated workforce
seems like an ambition that everyone can
get behind so what's going wrong what's
going wrong is under investment of
Education the donor community has
stagnated what it is investing in poor
countries for education over the last
nine years or so and it's estimated that
we're about thirty nine billion dollars
short on what would need to be spent to
really reach those those goals the truth
is if we carry on as we are complacency
we're walking towards an enormous
failure on the gold by 2030 so it's wake
up time otherwise by 2030 we will still
be seeing something close to a quarter
of a billion children adolescence and
youth out of school so presumably that
the donor countries are not the
countries who would directly benefit
from these donations they're the donor
countries aren't going to see any direct
benefit themselves well I think they do
see direct benefit actually because
countries where people are educated are
able to participate in society in the
economy where they can contribute to a
peaceful society they're not the
countries that are going to be having
the spillover problems which have
obviously impacted Germany and Europe so
much in recent times so I think it is an
investment in our common human security
to invest in education and support the
poorest countries to get every child in
school if we
look at the sustainable development
goals as a whole then education has an
impact on so many of them if you can
educate people you have a chance of
lifting far more out of poverty of
stopping the early marriage which is of
course keeping girls out of school and
Pakistan and other countries so this
research that UNESCO has put out for the
global education monitoring report and
I'm the chair of the advisory board now
and also the Institute of statistics is
very important because it says where
will he off track but if we did these
things we could be on track we use
Pakistan as an example in our report
Pakistan a country that's just been
approved for a six billion dollar IMF
loan so the country is having economic
problems donor countries are having
economic problems so where's the big
sell how do you convince a donor
countries and indeed the recipient
countries that this is to their benefit
there is something in this for you well
firstly no country ever developed
without very very significant investment
and the education of of its people it's
absolutely fundamental and now that
we're living in the world of the
knowledge society where we have to adapt
to new knowledge new technologies all
the time the countries that can't equip
their children with that knowledge and
those skills to acquire knowledge are
just going to get further and further
behind now one of the core principles of
the sustainable development agenda which
every country signed up to was leave no
one behind but on these trends we're
going to be leaving close to a quarter
of a billion children behind that's not
a recipe for peaceful world and that's
why I say it's in our common human
security to be addressing these issues
sorry if I sound like I'm laboring the
point but I'm wondering how you how you
make that sell directly to communities
we saw a poor fishing community there in
the film it's no point talking to them
about taking part in the knowledge
economy when they can't put food on the
table and they can barely find
facilities to to actually put a school
together that's right but education is
one of those investments which can break
through that cycle of poverty a child
with education
got more skills is able to be more
entrepreneurial is able to go to higher
levels of education can send money back
home into the village whether it's from
remittances or from a job in the city or
from a vibrant farm that's that's
actually able to be more productive so
education is the key to getting people
out of poverty people will stay stuck in
poverty if they can't rise out of
illiteracy in a numeracy good talking to
you we wish you well thank you for
joining us Helen Clarke from the UN
Development Programme